I think part of the problem is that  perpetrators up until now have been  largely invisible and unaccountable so I  do think that we need more narratives  that include I guess perpetrators and  their notions the the toxic ideas that  drive their actions because if we can  start to identify those that's the first  step towards uprooting them I was aware  of the lack of voices from perpetrators  from from men who committed this act to  to put that out in a public sense to  have it debated young yes scrutinized  and yes discussed and you're encouraging  people who may have gone through similar  circumstances as you have to come  forward and more quickly I suppose well  I need to make it very clear that I'm  not preaching a formula I have not  discovered a methodology I'm just  offering I guess my personal story up to  hopefully show that the blame does not  lie with survivors that there's hope  after rape that you can reclaim your  sense of self